nadim gemayel député à beyrouth bonsoir
monsieur jemaiel merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france comment expliquer le
regain de tension au liban qui a aussi
était confiné
comment expliquez-vous ce regain de
tension et ses manifestations contre le
pouvoir
tout à fait donc tout d'abord que ça
fait plus de deux mois que nous sommes
confinés donc le déconfinement a
commencé à beyrouth à partir du 5 5 juin
donc le 6 était une date pour reprendre
les manifestations qui ont commencé le
17 octobre et l'était les slogans de
base ou bien les sujets qui devaient à
traiter dans cette manifestation était
tout d'abord la démission du
gouvernement actuel qui n'a réussi à
rien faire durant ces six mois durant
plus de 100 jours de règne de
gouvernement deuxièmement une élection
législative prématuré et la demande pour
des élections législatives prématurée
afin de renouveler la classe politique
et de reprendre une certaine légitimité
populaire pour le pouvoir et
malheureusement le hezbollah aussi a pu
imposer une certaine autocensure à tous
les manifestants en ne demandant pas le
retrait des armes illégales du hezbollah
et surtout l'application de la décision
15 59 et 17,01 des nations unies qui
réclame expressément le dépôt de tous
les armes du hezbollah et de tous les de
toutes les factions militaires armés au
liban illégale car ça c'est une
revendication de longue date au liban
justement que le s voilà déposent les
armes
pourquoi est ce que le hezbollah on
s'est fait figure de
de police au liban non le hezbollah ne
fait pas ne fait pas du tout figure de
police au contraire il fait ses leçons
le la fonction aujourd'hui du hezbollah
est un juge arbitre joueurs au sein du
du pouvoir politique et surtout de la
balance politique tout d'abord mais
surtout c'est un c'est un régime
dictatorial s'éteint c'est un régime qui
est sous la botte iranienne et qui ne
souhaite peut imposer son sa politique
et sa mouvance politique à à tout le
peuple libanais est ce que nous refusons
carrément et cela il est prêt à le faire
par la force par la force de ces arbres
et c'est ce qui se passe durant c'est ce
qui se passe c'est ce qui s'est passé
durant les dix dernières années et si là
ce rôle prédominant en termes de
maintien de l'ordre en tout cas c'est
parce que l'état a failli selon vous
disons quelque part que c'est pas l'état
qui a failli disons que hilare et le
hezbollah réussit à mettre toutes les
institutions militaires et sécuritaires
de l'état sous la botte du hezbollah
très simplement surtout après l'invasion
de beyrouth le
le 7 mai 2008 le football a envahi by
route on se rappelle très bien il a
commis plusieurs meurtres il ya eu plus
de 60 à 110 tués et à ce moment là c'est
toute la structure politique et
sécuritaire du pays qui tombait sous la
botte du hezbollah aujourd'hui nous
sommes sous sous la tutelle ou bien sous
le gouvernement direct et la décision
direct qui a lui-même imposé sa loi
électorale qui a lui-même imposé le
président qui lui qu'il voulait qui a
lui-même imposée le gouvernement actuel
et c'est lui aujourd'hui qui dirige qui
contrôle le tout tout tout le pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes le liban est un
et 1 est un bar à carmel le gouvernement
est un barrague kernel le gouvernement
et ressemble très similaires mans au
gouvernement de vichy qui est qui et
soul sous la tutelle des iraniens et du
hezbollah et cela est pour nous
inacceptable nous ne sommes pas
aujourd'hui dans un liban indépendant et
souverain qui contrôlent ces ions d'une
façon autonome et d'une façon
indépendante
cela est inacceptable pour nous et c'est
pour ça que nous exigeons aujourd'hui la
levée des armes et de la mainmise du
hezbollah sur les décisions politiques
libanaises parmi les autres
revendications il ya également la
corruption de l'état
vous pensez que ces manifestations vont
pouvoir changer les choses tout à fait
aujourd'hui la grande revendication
aujourd'hui des manifestants était une
revendication sociale économique parce
que nous nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
une situation très très très précaire au
liban mais mais malheureusement à mon
avis là la solution ou bien la raison
essentielle du de ses problèmes
économiques et le choix économiques que
nous avons pris au liban depuis les 15
dernières années qui est un choix
économique très similaire aux régimes
syrien et iranien et nous avons
abandonné notre notre volonté de se
battre pour un régime économique
libérale capitaliste
libéral et indépendant et aujourd'hui on
en paye le prix
socialement on en paye le prix
économiquement et pour résoudre ce
problème économique et pour que les pays
occidentaux viennent nous aider
et pour qu'il puisse nous aider pour
qu'ils puissent nous nous donner nous
prêter des fonds
nous devons nous libérer politiquement
du joug iranien et syrien et du
hezbollah
jeudi dernier il ya une réunion
justement à ce propos entre le fonds
monétaire international et le
gouvernement libanais une solution est
envisageable
nous sommes en train de négocier pour
les solutions mais comme vous le savez
les solutions du les solutions du
gouvernement ou bien oui les solutions
du gouvernement ne sont pas en train de
prendre en ne sont pas en train de
prendre en considération les grands
chelems les grandes conditions du la
famille qui sont le contrôle des
frontières le contrôle des ports et de
l'aéroport et surtout beaucoup de
décisions relatives à alex et de
fonctionnaires dans l'état qu'ils sont
nous le savons très bien que les arbres
qui appartiennent à une certaine disons
groupes politiques et donc aujourd'hui
les grandes décisions et grands les
grands changements sont des changements
politiques ce ne sont pas seulement des
changements économiques ou sociaux et
cela dépend aujourd'hui de ce que je
veux ce que je vous ai dit tout d'abord
précédemment ce qui contrôle les
frontières sont hesbollah aujourd'hui
entre les frontières libano syriennes
ceux qui contrôlent le port et
l'aéroport c'est le fasse beau là avec
ses armes
ceux qui ont l'excédent dans les faux
dans les fonctions publiques c
les adhérents au parti en partie shalit
est donc aujourd'hui la les solutions
économiques sont des solutions
politiques et non seulement des
solutions économiques et la conséquence
c'est que 35% la population et est au
chômage
au liban à 45 % de la population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté au quotidien
comment est-ce que les libanais gère
cette situation écoutez c'est très très
difficile la dernière période a été
masqué un peu par le fait d'avoir des
doigts d'avoir eu le corona et nos
avions été en confinement pendant plus
de deux mois donc plus ou moins la
situation était masqué disons contre les
limiter mais je crois que dans les
quelques semaines à venir les libanais
vous commencez à sentir le poids le
poids de de cette situation économique
et sociale et ça va être à mon avis une
nouvelle catastrophe
les nouvelles un nouveau départ pour des
affrontements où vient pour de nouvelles
manifestations
merci beaucoup nadine jemaiel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france
rappelle merci à vous elle députés du
parti chrétien kateb haut à beyrouth
merci beaucoup c'est un parti libanais
avant d'être chrétien merci à vous